I get to I feel very grateful for I get
to be in conversation as an educator
about psychedelics to the public to
professionals like lawyers and doctors
but also to legislators I spend a lot of
time now speaking with people who are
elected both in the United States and as
well as around the world around like
what psychedelics are how they work and
in many cases as I can go into more
later
um how to talk about them without
sounding crazy and there are a lot of
people who are interested and who are
kind of interested in the closet but
what's happening is that the barrier to
entry to talking about psychedelics is
starting to reduce I think a lot of you
may be familiar but Maps is a nonprofit
that was founded at 01986. I don't know
how what the what the naming convention
is when you add the zero but I thought
that would be cute and we've been
sponsoring psychedelic assisted therapy
trials for the last 20 25 years and we
educate people to benefit from the
careful uses of psychedelic psychedelics
and marijuana so we're really an
educational research organization that
is really looking toward kind of I think
for a long time the frame and this is
true of a lot of drug policy the frame
was how do we dismantle the current
system and what I've realized in a lot
of what Maps works on and what I work on
with my colleagues that are here in
other places is the kind of the building
of the alternative infrastructure like
what is it that we go to we can kind of
dismantle the War on Drugs we can end
mass incarceration we can do all those
things and I really believe that we're
slowly slowly slowly but surely moving
toward that but there will need to be
systems that catch people because right
now the only ones we have are the ones
that are broken or fundamentally working
exactly how they're supposed to
depending on your frame
so Maps is the sole owner of the mouse
pillow benefit corporation which is
founded in to any 14.
and that organization works for drug
development so it's essentially a small
Pharma company that's working toward
therapy education and creating FDA
approved drugs so right now our Flagship
project which I'm sure a lot of people
are familiar with is taking MDMA
through through the FDA approval process
and I'm happy to announce that we just
we recently announced we just completed
our second phase three trial which means
we're now in the last leg before
submitting the NDA to the FDA hopefully
this year the maps has seven principles
that we operate on them they think that
they kind of help give a sense of the
conceptual Arc and the type of work that
we're trying to bring to the world
healing for all
prioritizing public benefit
open science open books I love this one
because I'm all about how do we make
things accessible to the public that are
usually esoteric unavailable knowledge
set the setting some of you are familiar
with the concept of set and setting but
we kind of believe in the city of
setting the setting like we're going to
be create we're actually building out
the setting in which uh political change
prohibition will change and so on as we
speak so there's this idea that we
actually have some agency there this
idea of Consciousness without
criminalization I'll talk a little about
a criminalization and decriminalization
specifically later on and this idea of
being the bridge we have a really kind
of a white umbrella under which we work
and you can imagine and as you've seen
more and more politically and I think
Andrew and I will talk about this a bit
in the Q a the type of people that are
attracted to psychedelics it's not
really just one type of person anymore
there was that concept for a long time
but that's really not true I think it
never was but there's this idea that
there's a particular type of person who
like looks a certain way and maybe
smells a certain way that's into them
but that's really starting to change and
the final one is my favorite which is
seeing past the Paradox which is just a
gen real concept when we approach these
big complex questions that relate to
criminalization in our future and where
we go from here
foreign